Je me mets aux gardes-à-vous
quand j'entends cette musique.
Luc Ferrandez et Anie Samson,
bonsoir. On ne refera pas toute
l'histoire du débat. C'était
bien suivi, on est vraiment
content, beaucoup de gens. On
croyait peut-être avoir une
perte que c'était le monde
municipal mais l'intérêt est
plus grand, souhaitons-le. Je
vous fais entendre un extrait,
M. Coderre et Mme Plante sur la
sécurité.
- Vous avez eu une vocation
tardive sur la question de la
sécurité; maintenant, vous vous
en occupez. Moi, là, vous avez
été là pendant quatre ans,
je veux dire, moi je ne suis pas
le maire, je veux le devenir,
je veux le redevenir,
ça n'a rien à voir. Mais sur
le terrain, les gens ont peur,
les gens ont besoin d'outils,
les gens ont besoin d'avoir plus
de policiers sur le terrain.
- Dire que la ville est
dangereuse, venant de la bouche
du candidat à la mairie,
je trouve que c'est mettre
de côté tout le travail de
celles et ceux qui assurent
notre protection.
- Alors qu'avez-vous pensé de
cet échange la sécurité peut-
être un exemple de ce qui est
arrivé plus largement dans ce
débat.
- Ça nous montre premièrement
félicitations pour hier soir,
vous avez fait cela de main de
maître. Pour ce qui est de la
sécurité, on avait une
différence entre les deux, c'est
rare qu'on voit que cette
position est différent. Je
donnerai des poteaux à Monsieur
Coderre sur la sécurité parce
qu'il sait de quoi il parle, de
la façon dont il en parle aussi.
Et évidemment, Mme Plante a déjà
eu un désaveu de la police dès
le départ avec M. Pichet qui est
parti, elle ne savait pas trop
occuper et elle a laissé Québec
décidé. Elle voulait couper, son
parti voulait couper dans le des
financements de la police. Je
voudrais que c'est un - zéro M.
Coderre
- Avantage Coderre pour la
sécurité. Alors il a gardé
l'avantage en ce débat.
- Je pense que Mme Plante est
peut-être mal parti mais elle
s'est bien rattrapée parce que
sa proposition n'est pas juste
une proposition d'ajouter des
policiers comme celle de
Monsieur Coderre qui voulait
ajouter 250 policiers mais il y
a aussi le travail va être fait
avec les groupes communautaires
de l'augmentation, le doublement
des budgets pour les gros
communautaires et les unités
d'intervention sociale et
communautaire. Elle est mal
partie, ce n'est pas un dossier
qui l'intéressait tant que cela
m'est dans les derniers mois et
malheureusement seulement dans
les derniers mois, c'est bien
rattrapé.
- La question et on a voulu le
simplifier, simplifier les
questions pour avoir l'attention
des gens et essayer d'arriver à
la substance de leur programme.
Est-ce que l'on développe ou
est-ce que l'on préserve? J'ai
donné l'exemple du golfe de
ville Anjou.
- Vous êtes prêt à développer
sur le dernier espace vert
d'Anjou? Pour moi, c'est un non-
sens parce que vous savez quoi,
Monsieur Roy, je vais finir ma
pensée, c'est que de nos jours,
il faut acheter des terrains
à fort coût, les décontaminer
et puis après ça les verdir.
Alors il me semble que
la logique, comme on l'a fait
avec le Grand parc de l'Ouest,
c'est de garder les espaces qui
sont déjà verts!
- Vous, le golf, vous le gardez?
Vous faites quoi avec le golf?
- Avec le golf? Bien, on peut
faire un parc. Absolument!
Il n'y a pas de parc
dans l'est de Montréal.
- Je pense qu'il faut remettre
les pendules à l'heure. Il n'y a
personne ici qui a dit que c'est
le développement économique au
détriment du développement vert.
Mais à un moment donné, il ne
faut pas juste dire : on va
acheter des terrains puis on n'a
pas tout l'argent pour le payer.
- Alors il y a quand même une
différence de vision entre les
deux.
- M. Coderre, ce que je lui
reproche pendant des années et
de ne pas approfondir ce
dossier. Il le fait plus
maintenant, il est moins papal
et plus concret mais pas sur ce
dossier. Sur celui-là il se
trompe royalement. On ne peut
pas toujours dire que l'on va
faire un peu de développement
économique et un peu préserver
l'environnement. Il y a des fois
quand il s'agit de préserver un
espace vert, la question ne se
pose pas. Et Mme Plante a pris
cela aussi. Parce que elle aussi
a fait ce genre d'erreur au
début en disant : pour ne pas
avoir la hante économique je
vais redonner une partie pour
construire Costco. Mais elle
attrapait hélas compris la
question de la préservation des
espaces verts Montréal, le grand
parc de l'Ouest, le golf de
ville d'Anjou et les corridors
de biodiversité. Monsieur
Coderre a l'air de dire que tout
est toujours possible. Mais non,
tout n'est pas toujours possible
pour
- Je ne suis pas d'accord avec
Luc mais c'est comme ça qu'on va
réussir à faire des débats.
C'est bien, réserver des
espaces, il faut aussi avoir
l'argent pour pouvoir les
acheter, les terrains. Il y a
aussi dans une ville comme je le
disais hier, il faut avoir de
l'économie, créer des emplois,
développer des quartiers, il
faut avoir une vision globale
sur l'ensemble d'une communauté.
Actuellement, ce qui me
préoccupe encore une fois, c'est
toutes les promesses que l'on
fait mais comment on va les
payer. Et cela, moi encore je
suis peut-être fatigant avec ça
mais c'est encore la poche des
citoyens qui vont à payer pour
acheter les terrains. Si on
construit on peut avoir des
revenus de taxes grandes
capables de les réinvestir.
L'argent, c'est une route que
l'on ne on ne peut pas le faire
pousser dans les parcs. Mais il
faudra qu'on ait de l'argent et
que l'on crée de la richesse. Et
on est capable de faire les deux
de façon très organisée et sans
dire que l'on va complètement
adroit ou complètement à gauche,
on est capable de trouver un
juste milieu pour le
développement de la ville.
- Je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec toi. Tu as un discours
raisonnable. Effectivement on ne
peut pas juste penser qu'on peut
dépenser et dépenser, ça ne
fonctionne pas. Dans les deux
plates-formes il y a beaucoup de
voeux pieux là-dessus. Mais sur
la valeur, l'achat des terrains
et la valeur de la ville,
Montréal d'un point de vue de
valeur immobilière, ça a
explosé. Montréal n'est pas en
décroissance au niveau de la
valeur immobilière mais plutôt
en augmentation forte. Alors il
faut quand même ne pas présenter
cela comme étant une
impossibilité d'acheter des
terrains.
- Sur les questions de logement,
de mobilité, et d'ailleurs sur
la question des camions dans les
quartiers, je m'attendais à ce
qu'il y ait des réponses plus
claires. On ne veut plus de 18
trous dans les rues
résidentielles! Mais je n'ai pas
vu cela.
- Monsieur Roy, sur cette
question des camions, il y en a
juste une réponse, c'est la
réglementation. Ça fait des
années qu'on entend les
politiciens parlers de la taille
des camions par exemple le
camion qui vient porter quelques
dizaines de boîtes de caisse de
bière avec un énorme camion qui
n'arrive pas à se faufiler dans
le pas. Il y a eu énormément
d'accidents en tournant à droite
ou à gauche avec des camions,
des piétons et des camions ou
des cyclistes. C'est la
réglementation de règles
problème il n'y a ni l'autre
n'ont accepté de le dire parce
que cela a un coût.
- Là-dessus ça existe la
réglementation, il y a un plan
de camionnage sur les deux
Montréal mais il n'est pas
appliqué. Les camions continuent
de passer, y en a un partout à
Montréal dans les rues,
l'association des camionneurs
est supposée avoir le plan et à
toutes les fois, en regardant
les rues qu'on a des
résidentielles qui comptent deux
milieux industriels ou
commerciale, les camions
continuent à passer. Lorsqu'on
demande aux policiers de faire
leur travail, et nous dit qu'il
faut prioriser, et c'est normal
on ne peut pas juste les asseoir
au coin des rues, ils ont besoin
de faire autre chose et c'est ce
qu'il fonctionnement pour rendre
la ville plus sécuritaire. Il
faut trouver d'autres moyens
pour
- Mme Plante nous a parlé du
projet à Barry avec les petites
voitures électriques, c'est très
bien mais pour une plus large
échelle de dire entre telle ou
telle heure, il n'y a pas de 18
trous alors c'est être très
simple.
- Ça serait plus facile à gérer
si on le met partout sur la
ville. Ça va être comme ça et
c'est le matin des livraisons,
et c'est tout.
- Et faire aussi une annonce
pour dans cinq ans pour laisser
le temps camionneurs de se
préparer et dire que d'ici cinq
ans ce sera des camions années
plats. On ne veut pas avoir un
camion avec un angle mort de 18
pieds devant le camion pour
- On va se présenter tous
ensemble pour
- C'est fini
- Qui s'est dégagée selon vous
de façon générale? Est-ce que
Mme Plante Monsieur Coderre ont
marqué des points? Vous êtes
couché en vous disant quoi hier
soir?
- Je me suis dit qu'on est
arrivé à un point tournant en
environnement, en logement, la
mobilité, en propreté, en
itinérance. Cela prend des
solutions très approfondies,
radical, transformatrice. Je ne
sais pas entendu hier soir
- Je suis resté sur mon apathie
sur la propreté. Le clip que
vous avez parlé présenter par
les points et surtout la
propreté de Montréal, c'est
lorsqu'on avait des gens dans la
maison, c'est notre maison et ça
ressemble à ce que l'on a vu
hier, c'est pitoyable. C'est la
première chose que la vie doit
faire, s'assurer que les rues
soient propres. À l'époque,
Monsieur Bourque faisait ses
rues et ses ruelles en auto, il
m'amène avec lui et dès qu'il
voyait un déchet il appelait la
directrice. Il a des poubelles
ici, venez nettoyer. Et
pourtant, c'est la base, c'est
la première chose qu'on a à
faire. Ce que j'ai vu hier, cela
m'a excellemment déçu parce que
c'est la priorité numéro un. Et
là-dessus je suis resté
vraiment, cela m'a déçu de voir
cela. Pour les autres points de
l'examen on a parlé de mobilité,
je dirais que Mme Plante était
peut-être plus en avant, Denis
Coderre beaucoup plus sur la
sécurité. Ça c'est balancé mais
à la fin, il est arrivé...
- En tout cas on les a entendu
parler.
- Oui et c'est correct, ils
avaient tous les deux beaucoup
de fluidité. J'ai aimé cette
fluidité. Les deux ont changé en
quatre ans parce que Monsieur
Coderre, rappelez-vous il y a
quatre ans, c'était : oui on va
arranger ça mais il ne disait
rien. Tandis que là, il rentre
dans le dossier il en parle, et
Valérie Plante a pris beaucoup
de contrepoids
- Vous dites que le niveau
général à monter mais pas assez
au pour régler les grands
problèmes structurels.